l'autoroute 50 va s'appeler l'autoroute
qui est la fleur
quel changement est immédiat pour rendre
hommage au célèbre démon blanc merci Guy
Lafleur tous ces moments de fierté que
vous nous avez donné
l'annonce a été faite
les membres de la famille de Guy lafla
au nom de toute la famille la fleur je
tiens à remercier le gouvernement du
Québec d'avoir officiellement intégrer
le nom de mon père dans le riche
patrimoine de notre province
dans la communauté la nouvelle est
accueillie avec joie
maintenant
Guy Lafleur c'est tout un ananas c'est
une fierté c'est une fierté pour pour
les gens te ressources c'est surtout une
fierté pour la famille puis je pense
qu'en
toujours en l'honneur de Guy Lafleur se
concrétise il sera déposé prochainement
sur la route dans les sports et dans les
mémoires qui la fleur n'est pas oublié
ici Rebecca Quan Radio-Canada sursaut